I think so often not only on film but in
life we so want to feel comfortable but
that doesn't always bring the best
results don't sit back don't wait for
the bank loan to come through don't wait
for people to find your product or for
the advertiser to call you do whatever
you have to do hustle hustle hustle when
the things most matter you so
desperately don't want to destroy it for
being scared that you can really destroy
it need motivation believe nation what's
up at seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
make a difference with it so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and show
in today's lessons from a man who went
from being abandoned by his mother when
he was eight years old being raised by
his father was a bit of a rebel and
loved playing sports and turned all of
that into an acting career and becoming
one of Hollywood's biggest stars
he's Hugh Jackman and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one my personal favorite step
outside your comfort zone
I remember a mckellen saying to me just
because it feels uncomfortable doesn't
mean it's not good and I remember my
doing the first x-men movie was a little
I came in late I felt a bit behind the
8-ball I started shooting four weeks
into filming because I was replacing the
guy who was playing the role so I came
in feeling a bit behind the eight ball
and there was a rhythm going and I I
just felt a bit uncomfortable and and I
I remember him giving me that advice he
goes your stuff is good and on even if
it feels uncomfortable that can
sometimes be right I think so often not
only on film but in life we so want to
feel comfortable but that doesn't always
bring the best results if I look back I
think some of my more successful things
in my point of view have been the things
I've been most nervous about and
probably most unsure when I began
there's something about jumping off that
cliff which means you end up going for
broke and probably end up taking a few
more risks if you know what I mean rule
number two be in control
you're entrepreneurs out there what role
has failure played in your life or what
advice do you give I remember when I
went into acting I was like the only
businesses that worked but when the
owner for the first five years would
work seven days a week
basically it was their baby so when I
graduated I thought I'm gonna not wait
for the phone to ring one day that was
my commitment for five years I thought
if I can't pay the rent after five years
I'm out so I would say that is a basic
rule it's sort of work for me don't sit
back don't wait for the
going to come through don't wait for
people to find your product or for the
advertiser to call you do whatever you
have to do hustle hustle hustle if it
hasn't worked after four years keep
going if it hasn't worked after 20 years
stopped immediately and stop borrowing
money from the Barons no but give it a
certain period and have a plan for that
five years you need to be able to be
accountable so after six months used to
say we're not hitting any target we were
going to open that shop three months ago
why haven't one so you have to keep
adjusting accommodating we started this
business seven years ago
I honestly thought we'd be where we are
today probably about three years ago
rule number three embrace fear you
suffer from bit of anxiety when you're
in front of the camera hmm but that you
name your you're confident personality
Frank yeah oh my god and you're in joy
and you're anxious personality Charles I
mean the most scared I've ever been was
being asked to sing at the MCG for the
bladders like up and I'm a big rugby fan
toys were up in Sydney so rugby was my
sport and I said come and sing and I
actually had a panic attack the night
before because all the people I was at a
dinner party and people were telling
stories of how careers had finished by
singing a dad doesn't to her anymore
I'll tell you that does not happen and
that someone got up and sang it acapella
got off-key got booed literally singing
the anthem and I have never been more
scared than that moment and I what
happened to me in film was it was random
it would appear sometimes and that was
something I never encounter I understand
if you're scared of heights or always
get arts but some days I'll be fine and
then some days I would just get nervous
and then to get in my head so I don't
know if you guys know Anthony Robbins
you know the other motivational
motivational do yes yeah I mean he does
motivator he's not really motivational
guy actually he's really quite brilliant
in breaking down how we think the
patterns of behavior we have and so I
met him we were mates I never went to
him to I never went to one of his
workshops we were just friends and I
really I said might I want to come to
you professionally I need to ask you a
question and that's he said to me what
the biggest mistake people make with
fear is saying I'm scared get I hate
this get it out I don't want you near my
life this is not helping me and you
obviously really wound up so he said
you've got to remember the times we feel
confident name that character name the
character that feels scared and as
you're walking on a set realize that the
fear is good that a got you where you
are that it makes you work the fears
sometimes actually goes on I better work
really hard on this film like when I
with lame is I was really nervous so he
said that fear
embrace it worked really hard and on
that day when you walk on set Charles
Charlie Charles thanks but I don't need
you right now and then be Frank as in a
total [ __ ] so don't care about in
enough and that somehow switch to me in
when occasion we get nervous rule number
four be friendly with everyone I
genuinely like to be friendly with
everyone in the Australian film industry
everyone talks to everyone and if
they're not making fun of you then they
really don't like you
so there's a problem and I also when I
first went to America I noticed there
was an unspoken it's not people tell
stories have done look this actor in the
eye and all that I've never heard that
before but there is a slightly unwritten
rule of leave the actor alone let them
do their thing it could be our process
it could be because their style not sure
and I always try literally on the first
day to break that down because I feel
self-conscious in that environment I'd
much prefer a grip you know making fun
of me then calling me mr. Jackman and
then not saying nothing until they say
thank you for there's been great working
with you you know i much prefer to feel
we're in it together rule number five be
honest with yourself when you tell
yourself on your worst days always say
okay what could I have done honestly and
if you can't do that honestly you better
have someone around you that can it was
a point of one of my first films I got
so angry with the director he pulled me
up and was kind of saying some things to
me basically you are doing a bad job you
know
and I was saying to dad I said you know
his director and after rain she listened
to and she said a Konami honestly then I
said yeah and she goes I don't think
you've done that work I'm doing the
research I'm doing the work of knowing
what you are the scene to be yeah let's
call me up and was I partly right about
the director short but actually the
thing I take away from that was her
going you could've done better rule
number six have a champions mindset
Jackman told us that the only time he
didn't listen to his wife was when she
urged him to refuse the role these films
made him wealthy and he emerged an
international star it's a physical part
for which Jackman sculpts both beard and
body and she invited us to his to a day
workouts that didn't fillies this
morning impressive impressive I always
say when I lift something maybe I
remember that is Wolverine uh-huh a
little bit the way you go I want to drop
it and then you go no way that little
bit is Wolverine you change bodies the
way other actors change costumes well
this is your tool as much as your voice
as much as your emotions and so I've
always taken that very seriously and I
love playing Wolverine it's a great
character but I want it to be better
than the last time I want to be
physically in better shape otherwise
there's no point doing it look you're a
successful guy you don't have anything
to prove to anyone you have this little
voice in your head telling you to do
more to better than if I didn't have
that I wouldn't be sitting here opposite
you at the same time for the sake of
people around me it'd be nice to be
outta there down for a while you know
rule number seven follow your instincts
homo count to three and you're gonna
start walking away a tri-service one I
have a lawyer now too
three boss I had no idea I remember
finishing the first movie and a maid a
miner was in Hollywood it was a player
in Hollywood he goes dude I've heard not
very good things about the movie
you really should book something else
before it comes out so there's about a
four-month gap he goes just make sure
you got something else cuz when it comes
out you're back down the bottom of the
pile again you know happily he was wrong
but I mean no one really knew there was
no comic book genre there was you know
common work movies were really not
around at the time I had no idea it
would be 17 years and then I think with
this one honestly what happened was I
had a dinner with Jerry Seinfeld was a
friend of mine I was asking him about
the end of the series I said how did you
decide and long story he kind of said
look I've always believed creatively
you should never spend everything
creatively because it's almost Herculean
to start up again you should always have
something in the tank leave the party
before he gets too late kind of theory
and then somehow it spurs you into the
next thing and then as he was talking I
went home and I said to Deb on my way
home in a cab I said we've um this is
the last one is what and I said I just
know this is the last one and I woke up
the next morning with this very strong
idea which Jim Mangal and I've been
working on of treating it not like a
comic movie in any way treating him not
like a superhero but as a human being
you know with who's lived a life of
violence and let's make a movie about
the ramifications of violence and I was
thinking The Wrestler I was thinking
Unforgiven that kind of thing and the
moment I'd had that thought I was
supercharged super excited absolutely
sure I wouldn't play it again and very
nervous because it's 17 years I mean
you're a theater man like me it's like
at the end of a long run you really want
your last show to be the best well you
just you don't want to finish on a bad
note and it wasn't until I saw the
premiere in Berlin and I literally at
the end I cry I and it was gratitude to
Jim mangled who pulled off something
I'll forever be in debt to him 17 year
journey and also just actually seeing on
screen
what I'd held in my head and heart as a
possibility for the character rule
number eight have fun when the things
most matter you so desperately don't
want to destroy it for being scared that
you can really destroy it when I hosted
the Oscars I was I was like wow man this
is a billion people and I just thought
okay whatever you do just remember
you're a kid from moronga in sydney
you're hosting the Oscars have some fun
you know and luckily for me those
turning points I've somehow always stuck
to that idea of just having fun
rule number nine commit fully every time
he has to do one of these the work
involved which people don't see is how
hard he works on just getting the body
right for it I mean it just such strict
diet and workout and he's lifting away
there ya have another slab of chicken
and then thirteen years ago to that
point
well basically train for three hours a
day and eat a lot of protein a lot of
food and I actually got the diet from
Dwayne the rock Johnson has made a mine
and every day what I do is I eat for
eight hours and I fast for sixteen and
so from about 10:00 in the morning till
6:00 for this I eat way too much and
then nothing after that
very very bit and will number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
clips be great at what you do
[Music]
I
[Music]
now I've got three really special bonus
hugh jackman clips around finding great
people knowing your why and taking on
challenges but before that I want to
know what did you learn from this video
which rule have the biggest impact on
you and why leave it down the comments
below I want to hear from you thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much loved I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
any movie musical is like Mount Everest
I think it's the most difficult form
every to pull off in film when it works
it's spectacular when it doesn't it
stinks to high heaven
this film is either gonna be a hit or
it's gonna be a massive bust yep
why did you take the risk on it Jean
Valjean is the holy grail for me it's I
know that it demands everything from me
as a singer as an actor to pull it off
it's the role of a lifetime and I know
it's easy and you hear people all the
time thanking their team their agents
and it always feels like perfunctory
well when I came to Hollywood I was
about 30 years old I wasn't a kid I felt
I understood people a little bit I had
no idea really I met a thousand people
and three of those people I met are
still with me today 15 years later and I
my whole approach to meeting them and
trying to decide who was gonna work with
was the Aussie good bloke rule because I
had no idea if anyone could do their job
I mean everyone seemed great to me
so I just applies if they seem like a
good bloke if they seem like they're
true to the word if they seem like
they're genuine then I'm gonna go with
it and I did I just lucked out not only
are they good blokes they're
unbelievable of their job choices making
choices I've learned the hard way
sometimes doing things that I didn't
feel were right went against my gut on
it that's hard and now I do I really try
to avoid that now even and and and
actually failure if you really believe
no when you say yes it's fine I love you
I don't know I'm with you yeah if if you
if why you if you know why you did
things right and you're kind of pure and
you're in that you can live what
whatever the outcome is yeah because you
can't control everything right so you
can only control your intention and your
kind of yeah you're good impulse you're
your degree of engagement yeah and and
that in fact if when you're free of the
idea of the result sometimes the
engagement can run so much deeper you
know because you're not preoccupied in
thinking ahead you're not getting ahead
of yourself you're doing this for this
yep raise your standard Apple at the
core its core value is that mm-hmm
that people your passion can change the
way people not one drop of myself work
depends on your it's supposed to mean
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details